let's go ahead and finally take it
off dang okay guys I have to be honest I
am actually nervous I was initially
excited to wear this thing for a full 8
hours while working without taking it
off but now that it's coming time to do
that man now I am going to switch out
this strap I've actually worn this for
about 3 and 1/2 hours and it was not too
bad but I hear that this thing is way
more comfortable let's go ahead and try
this
on and just like that I am in the
augmented world and the 8 hours has
started and I guess one of the cool
things is that you guys will get to see
behind the
scenes now one thing walking around with
these on you get some motion shake some
little up and down motion that you
normally wouldn't get and with that the
one thing I wish was that was better is
is the pass through quality because all
of the text icons everything rendered is
so incredibly detailed and it works so
well but seeing people in the
environment you guys look like you're a
720p in this but the crazy thing is you
do get used to it after about 10 15
minutes half an hour that kind of
becomes your normal reality and that's
just what it is now people have asked
how can you connect to a Mac that
doesn't have a screen that is on if you
look at this screen I'm not getting any
popup showing connect to this display
because it is not that but I can still
pop in the control
panel press this button bam my MacBook
Pro shows
up my screen turns off there and Bam
look at that so I went from a 6K 32in
display now to this full big display you
can easily resize it make it larger but
you can only have one of these maybe
because this thing is still limited by
an M2 Chip that limits you to One
display and one crazy thing is I don't
have to keep my display at my desk I can
literally spin around make this whole
wall be my display block out that window
stretch it out as big as I want to grab
my keyboard and maybe my mouse and be
chilling against this wall now with that
I don't even have to stay there just
grab this my macet stay in that other
room I can come join Ben over here oh
hey what's up hey and now we can both
share this space I mean this display is
I don't know 200 in or more and I could
edit here and of course the quality
looks a lot better what I'm seeing
compared to what you guys see in the
screen recording now as you guys could
see my virtual display is behind my
actual one and so I see the out outline
there so that's kind of annoying of
course I can grab it and I can bring it
closer and it looks incredible in
spatial of the spatial design you guys
are seeing a 2d version of it so now it
looks perfectly sharp and the cool thing
is when you bring it super close to you
it actually makes it smaller so it could
just fill in your full vision without
getting out of the way or the other
option is going into my virtual space
like that so now I can bring it further
out
and I can go ahead and make it way
bigger like this and the quality of this
is
absolutely
incredible now it's really cool being in
this virtual environment and I can
actually hear birds at a distance these
speakers do an incredible job and then
if I need to look over at venny here he
actually passes through so I can talk to
him I'm not trapped in a virtual world
and if you want to you could just blend
it and that works super super well so
right now you guys can see my keyboard I
can keep that visible I can keep these
guys visible and when I'm just looking
up I'm in this virtual space all right
guys you have to check this out I took
some time to set up my environment in a
way that would actually be useful
instead of just you know making a larger
screen you guys see there's a lot of
Windows all around me and it's kind of
hard to see it in this bright room so
I'm going to go ahead and put myself
into the virtual space here and take a
look at this right in front of me I have
my Mac display and I'm going to be
opening up Final Cut there above here I
have a podcast turned on with the Juno
app to the right I have a widget with my
time my calendar and I like to keep up
with some stocks so I got that open on
the left side I have a web browser I'm
going to be doing some research checking
out the latest news so I can easily
scroll and a lot of times we're doing
doing testing so I have a stopwatch down
there and then I have my notes app so I
can take some notes and above the files
app so all of this I can easily be
sitting here looking over to the side
take a quick glance and it's so crazy
how quickly you can actually switch
through and since I have my Mac
connected I can use my keyboard right
here just to type some notes and I don't
have to just look over to the side I
actually have it right in front of me as
well to make it easier to see what I'm
actually typing so everything just works
really well together now with that I'm
typically a person that doesn't use my
voice to type or I don't use Siri but
with the Vision Pro I'm actually finding
myself saying Hey Siri open
Messages bam it pops up and then now I
can grab this and using my keyboard I
could just type a text and send it and
another super cool thing that I just
found is that with apps that that
support drawing on the iPad you can
literally just use your finger and draw
and write and it is surprisingly
responsive and the same thing goes for
signing a document if you need to open
it up in the Vision Pro just going to
grab it pull it out in front of me
here hit
markup and give a nice little
signature saved so far I have to say
that this is a lot more impressive than
I expected especially because the screen
resolution and how many things you can
have open in the virtual space all
around you where in the real world even
if you have multiple monitors you're not
going to get the same kind of experience
so now it's time for me to grab these
cards right here insert them into uh my
readers and do some video editing now my
favorite part about the Vision Pro is
that you can merse yourself and cut out
all the distractions so you can focus on
things like brainstorm using this cool
new app from our sponsor xmind which
which lets you create mind maps within a
3D virtual space and truly visualize
your thoughts with professionally
designed structures like various tables
and charts intuitive tools customizable
themes and styles and more you can
download the xmine app on Apple Vision
Pro right now to start your mind mapping
today now unfortunately I already have
run into a major issue that is unfixable
but the first thing I want to show you
guys is this what I just realized is
that this is Apple first computer that
does not have any digital connection
whatsoever so it's practically portless
other than the power there's no way for
you to just plug it in to get files
thankfully airdrop and everything works
just fine so right now I'm going to go
and airdrop to my Mac bam it's sending
all those screen recordings and I can
keep editing now the issue that I found
is a pretty major one right now I've
been doing editing here and I have my
podcast opened up right here so if it's
turned on I'm hearing it in my earpods
but then when I go ahead and go and
start
editing while I don't hear anything at
all and that is because my MacBook
cannot be connected to my earpods at the
same time as the Vision Pro and in the
control settings I cannot stream the
audio from my Mac to the headset
like I can do with the video so even
though I have all this blend of stuff on
division Pro and on my Mac that comes
perfectly you can't share one source so
then if I want to listen to the podcast
I could do that or if I connect the
airpods to my Mac it disconnects from
The Vision Pro and then now if I play
that it's going to play through the
headset itself now I could just use one
of these and try to you know listen to
both at the same time but then it's
playing for other people as well and I
think that's a major oversight so now
I'm to close the podcast in The Vision
Pro and manually open it up on my Max
display that way I can listen to the
audio from my video and that at the same
time and then you're still stuck to one
virtual screen even though it's large
that definitely needs to somehow be
fixed so now I'm going to go ahead and
put on my airpods m
and I'm going to just go ahead and dial
this in and I think I'm going to go in
here and customize it set it to dark
mode bam now the contrast that I see
right here is incredible and let's get
some of this editing done now I have
almost 7 Minutes of this edited I was
editing for a while and I have to share
my experience here it was really really
good being able to see this in a screen
size that is probably 60 70 in is nice
all the text was nice and sharp no
issues
whatsoever I think the main thing that
started to bug me were my airpods Mac so
the cool thing is I can quickly double
press and it takes all of that away the
headset itself with this band is
extremely comfortable and I wore it for
about 3 to 4 hours before I put on the
airpods max I had no issues and after
about an hour I started getting some
pain but it's from my headband that is
worn out and then taking this thing off
and editing without them I started
feeling a lot better already and at this
point I've had to re-shoot a couple of
these clips cuz I didn't have the audio
recording on it is almost 4:00 that's
been uh what is that 7 hours already
pretty much 7 hours um the comfort is
really good and I'm not getting any uh
heat or any buildup or anything in here
the airpods max will get hot where your
ears are after a while but I'm surprised
by how comfortable this whole setup was
now one really cool thing say you have
to go to the bathroom which I had to do
you can literally just step up and start
walking out and then you just get back
into your normal set like right there I
have that one display as you guys could
see um it's kind of dark now it's coming
back in um that will stay there and then
if I go to the bathroom here I can
actually come here press and decide hey
I want to open up an app over here let's
do Safari you can grab it paste it
wherever you want to so if you need a
little break um you can be using your
display and then when you're going back
into your office setup you guys can see
that the display is still on it's still
connected to my Mac and as I walk up bam
automatically back in full immersion in
my virtual space here and that has has
been incredible and with that if you set
up other environments too I can come
over here everything just stays I have
this app store over here if I'm going to
come refill um you know some coffee get
some water I have a calendar set up and
if I want to take a little break from
work which I wasn't doing you can just
sit down look at this and just go ahead
and start playing back a video and
enjoying yourself and it's crazy how
everything stays tracked for pretty much
ever and now I got most of that video
edited other than this ending here and
today I need to get some payroll done a
little bit of tax stuff and the nice
thing is I can actually sit down right
here I don't have to stay at my desk I
have my keyboard here and now I can just
go ahead and pull this up let's just
open up a safari window I'm going to
drag this over here let's grab another
tab let's go ahead and make that tab
over there and then I can come
in open up QuickBooks open up Google
Sheets right over here then if I want to
pull up my calendar get some info and
now I could literally just chill over
here get all that stuff done and not
have to just sit at my desk now another
cool thing that I found is that I don't
have to have all this distractions over
here of course I can go in and change my
environment which is really cool but if
I press and hold I can hide all the
other apps and literally just focus on
this one thing that I need right now all
right guys so it has been officially 8
hours of me wearing the Vision Pro and
honestly at the beginning I thought that
I would want to just take this thing off
and I'd be so tired of it because with
other other VR headsets you'd have them
on for 30 minutes an hour and you just
want to take it off but this thing has
done a great job
and the one thing that I wish I can get
right now would be the ability to use
Mac OS on this thing basically goes back
to like with iPads as well I'd love to
be able to control Final Cut with my
hands the gesture support and being able
to just quickly open things up switch it
I wish I could just grab my timeline cut
something grab some sliders and not have
to use this traditional setup of a
keyboard and mouse that we've used for
years because because once you get used
to it it is just so quick to be able to
look at something open it close it um it
is a very very good UI experience and I
want to be able to use this more so that
makes me just want more from Apple and
I'm excited for the second generation
version but with that said if you wanted
to know what it's like to use this for a
workday it's a lot better than you would
expect and you could absolutely go
without a regular display go about your
day and you have way more
customization more so than you can even
have with two or three monitors at your
space and even though it's been over 8
hours I'm not going to take this off yet
I still have some things to do and I
feel comfortable enough that I don't
need to I'm just going to use my setup
and get it done all right guys it has
been 9 hours so far let's go ahead and
finally take it
off dang you guys are like 8K quality
now
oh man oh my goodness um yeah that's
pretty crazy the first thing is that
light is bright everything's so bright
in here cuz this takes the brightness
down evens it out uh obviously nowhere
near sharp but it was insane how after
about 15 20 minutes I got used to having
a lower resolution and what shocked me
the most is at first I was really scared
to wear it for8 hours I thought it would
suck but it didn't and even at the end I
wanted to use the extra features and be
able to get St done with it um I had no
issues with discomfort um with heat or
anything how does my face look is it all
red or anything yeah there's a red line
but with this headband I did not feel
any weight the airpods Maxs had more
weight on me when I wore those for uh a
couple hours so overall I'm way more
impressed now with the Vision Pro and
what it could do and it really is a
spatial computer I am going to be using
it there's no way that I'm going to
return this thing uh I'm excited for the
future and if you guys want to see me
wear this for a full 24 hours going
around doing a bunch of other stuff not
just a workday with editing and emails
and stuff let me know down below go
ahead and click that Circle above check
out one of those great videos right over
there this has been Max and I'll see you
in the next
[Music]
one